[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 34 of
GameSpot after dark or part two of the
work from the Home Edition I think I'm
gonna try to keep track of this and see
how many work from home editions we can
get to
but anyway joining us this week is
Callie plaguey Lucy James and two more
Huseyin hi uh he's here to tell us all
about blood burns anniversary right yep
I'm ready I did a Twitter thread about
I'm just gonna read that
okay that's fine okay even read it so
that would be perfect I'm not but
genuinely I did that Twitter thread and
it took me about two and a half hours to
compose it and it's like four tweets but
I was like it took forever for me to
like make sense of it and the whole
thread is about how I don't understand
blood-borne I'll have you enjoy after
this episode though before we get
started though I do have one
announcement by the time this goes live
it's Wednesday today it'll go up Friday
as hopefully you know by now the discord
should be live we got the okay to get it
going I think we're gonna mod for now
and see how it goes from there but yeah
if you're interested in being a part of
discord you can message me on Twitter or
message John Luke actually he might be a
better one to message because he's the
one who set it up or you can email the
after dark after dark at eff the dark
podcast at Gamescom i'll get it one of
these days and we can add you that way
but yeah now is probably a good time to
join because there's not a lot going on
you might want some people to talk to
about video games and whatnot but anyway
shall we get started what we've been
playing / doing mm-hmm
Callie do we start sure here honking
it's someone's that's that's me sorry
there's a goose outside who Lucy had
sirens going on
last I heard sirens I think it's an
earthquake's recording something this
week there's Lessing blessing tweet
weird listening to last week's episode
of games but after dark and hearing Greg
in the background recording it last
week's PS I love you I sent you I think
I sent a gif of I was watching I think
it was games or one of the one of the
parties and like Greg is talking about
something and in the distance you can
see just loosely like walk into frame
look directly at his camera how many
pieces have kind of funny content I can
just sneak into sort of like dab very
very regularly will reference you he
does he's done it way more recently than
before I remember early on and kind of
funny when they first hired Kevin they
didn't show Kevin's face at all for like
the first yeah I don't know nine months
or so for a very long time and they
finally did it reveal I thought that was
that was pretty funny so instead you can
just like not be on the content but also
on all of the content anyway Callie what
have you been up to
I'm still playing Animal Crossing cuz
I'm doing a lot of Animal Crossing
guides and thank you I did it trying to
make sure everybody knows how much you
can sell did her fish for and yeah I
paid off my final loan today
so relations I had to figured to
capitalism I did defeat capitalism today
kind of bye-bye
cow telling to it yeah I mean I don't
think that yeah I I had like a crazy
high turnip price today so I took
advantage of that after Jake Joe I
missed the turnip lady because I didn't
realize they came they left at midday
and I logged on on Sunday at ten past
twelve a HUD sucks
yeah yeah I like him too this week this
is like the first time I've ever [ __ ]
with the stock market in anal crossing
cuz I just like I don't know I didn't
Eve I just didn't even want to mess with
it didn't want to worry but it's kind of
like in real life how I don't know
anything about socks I'm just like I'm
like that stocks image I don't
understand but I I have been trying it
cuz Daisy May is really adorable and it
paid off today because I made like I
made like 1.2 million bells today at one
point one point four whoa
so jeez I made a lot of money in Animal
Crossing I'm gonna get my final villager
cuz I put that off for some reason and
he is his name is Lyman he is a koala
Lana he mean I'm not crazy about him it
was a random thing that happened to me
and my store still hasn't frickin
upgraded I've I've made millions in
stock market and I've paid off all of my
loans amounting to millions I've spent I
bought the crown which is a million
bells and I still don't have an upgraded
store so I'm starting to get a little
annoyed I got really excited today
because this is the first time I've ever
dropped anything and the you know those
sell been right outside of the Nook
store if you drop stuff off there you'll
get paid the next day but you won't get
paid as much as if you just sold it to
him right away I haven't done that
before until last night cuz I caught a
bunch of fish that I don't really care
about so I was like I'll just throw them
in there cuz otherwise I just released
some and then the next morning I got a
phone call from Timmy and I got super
excited and I set up my recording
equipment because I'm like this is it
they're gonna be like yo we need you at
the store right now cuz we're gonna
upgrade this thing and then and then I
press a a couple more times like you got
six thousand dollars from or six
thousand bells from your fish and I was
like damn it Timmy come on give me the
new store hey we are on day
actually let me I'm gonna tab over and
actually tell you we're on a 77 today's
any seventh day that Jake and I have
played this game and we still have next
cranny I'm I'm actually like this is
actually like a big not a big but it's
definitely a negative point for me I'm
still really enjoying me Verizon's um
and I I I'm waiting until I upgrade the
store to fully finalize my review
because I want to speak to that as an
important part of progression and I have
been disappointed with the way the
progression has worked so far
as far as like overall town progression
I think you have a lot a lot more to do
day to day which is strength but I think
there's I'm hoping like they do some
sort of update or something cuz it is
way too I'm waiting a month for a new
store is like uh it used to be like
eight days yeah who's gonna say for
reference like in previous games it's
been like a week or when you spend
twelve thousand bells it'll upgrade it
and then there'll be multiple upgrades
after that we don't even know if there
are more upgrades after this first one
right for the second I guess the only
confirmed building so far are the
upgraded nook's cranny which by the way
is still called looks cranny which makes
me think that's the last one it worries
me so much and then able sisters so I
heard the guide a while ago I don't know
what's gonna happen to that shipping
with everything going on you can
probably get a Kindle vision yeah I was
thinking about doing that cuz I do have
a Kindle with enough space for pictures
this is for manga but I could probably
get a Kindle version of the guide
because I want to know I like I even
reached out to PR and I was like can you
please tell me how to do like I'm lost
how do I do this um so that's been
that's been weird I know like obviously
part of New Horizons is those plant
updates for holidays that put the
holidays in the game so you can't time
travel to them and we were thinking
maybe that could add stuff but that
doesn't really make sense because people
start the game at all different times
like not everybody played at day one so
yeah I mean they said they were doing a
drop is it March end of March they were
doing that first um so that the the one
point one
I know update is what we're on now and
then was the first update like for
launch day and then for bunny day which
is like animal Crossing's Easter I think
that doesn't come like come into the
game until like the day before or
something like that yeah
at least that's what I heard I think
there's a lot of like rumors and
misinformation like there's this fish we
can't catch and I think people are just
wrong about what month that's in so
we're in a weird stage with Animal
Crossing right now with no official
guide to to guide us my bet is that I
bet my bed is that I think a lot of that
stuff will be coming through updates in
DLC because there's some stuff that
we've seen no signs of like Brewster's
cafe I think is a big one like that that
kind of became a staple of Animal
Crossing I feel like I don't know ever
since wild world a big part of that game
was checking in on Brewster getting
coffee and then a new leaf they added
that minigame to right where you can
yeah I served villagers coffee
yeah picking they're like knowing their
coffee order and getting it for them and
then you would get like the different
coffee items to put in your house as a
reward yeah I I mean the updates so far
that they haven't talked about the
holiday ones at least are free so I'm
hoping that any further stuff is not
like I would take a day for Brewster um
yeah yeah I mean like even crazy red
like I have not encountered any art
which is another like that goes back to
the very beginning of Animal Crossing
it's just just a strange I
it's a strange limbo we're in right now
because like I'm writing a lot of these
guides and there's still so much I don't
know and it's not just me like I've been
talking to other people I've been
talking to people at IGN and like just
talking to different games media people
and everybody's just kind of like I
don't really know what is next
yeah it's just a weird time all around I
think you know so but the animals are
still really cute and every time they
sing I almost cry so yeah
I've been running into a lot of animals
singing it's it's very wholesome I love
it
did you see the one yet Alessandra
Barbosa are one of our freelancers he
tweeted two animals singing together hmm
do you guys have the chicken which
chicken
yeah which the one that ends the one
that ends every sense with cheeky poo
jake has that one yeah I do I forget him
I don't like it much either plucky
plucky clucky
yeah it's plucky plucky is useless it
says nothing of interest ever just ends
it with cheeky poo oh my gosh you're
useless yeah I've been waiting I haven't
I haven't had the heart to kick plucky
out yet I've been hoping that pluck
you'll be like you know what I think
it's time for me to move but instead
this other villager I like named chevre
like once a week is like I had a dream
I'm gonna move I think I might move it
I'm like no no please don't move I like
you
we got to get gotta get plucky out of
here though Braves yeah in Rivia
villager whose name is just Kyle so he's
cool but like I got a monkey named Tammy
to join me in 10 stir damn it's very own
brand and for a minute I was like I
wonder if there's enough characters
we've just time at the start of their
name that I could exclusively make it a
time Island and I was like now I don't
remember there being any more in fact I
mean you can look you can go on the wiki
and just like ctrl F tan yeah what comes
just there's Timmy and Tommy time me and
then Tammy will be there so there's like
there's a theme there's a theme that's
incredible house thrilled ho doing Lucy
thrill ho is thriving I'm getting the
resident services tomorrow
no damn tomorrow it's been closed
tomorrow I'm enjoying it
although my house is really basic I'm in
an animal crossing discord and
everyone's showing off what they have
and I'm like
sucks but I'm gonna try to inshallah
Island tonight I think my house is sorry
I was gonna say my house is completely
empty there's a fax machine on the floor
and then above it is the poster of the
Diamond Dogs logo from metal gear fire
and that's it that's the only thing I've
got stuff from slack now I'm living a
minimalist life I got the fax machine if
anyone needs me for any missions and
they know that I represent Diamond Dogs
that's it that reminds me of like just
buildings and pub key where they'd just
be like a printer and that would be it
not even the fax machine is on the floor
in the middle of the room perfect oh
that would have been so good advance
evan named his island outset which i
thought was really good yeah I've seen :
- okay that's a good one which I think
those Brian altano is I think that makes
sense and then of course noted
spokeswoman for sucker punch that is a
translation error on Twitter inside
jokes I shouldn't even mention it but
anyway Andrew Goldfarb is doing a whole
ghost of Tsushima themed room
and he's been asking various people to
send him things so I've been sending him
like samurai [ __ ] and like old sushi so
what I'm doing is like I've I'm creating
themed quadrants on my island so I have
the beach area and I went to an island
yesterday where there's bamboo thickets
and I like ate all the coconuts in the
island so I could take all those bamboo
thickets and the other left-hand side of
my island is gonna be like the the Asian
area and then I'm gonna do like a
futuristic area in the top left so it's
got like different biomes I love that
like the Crystal Maze yeah that's my
plan for Hamsterdam
Lucy what is you wanna tell us what the
tiger king is oh my god
oh my god so Jen Greg and I my roommates
and I we're playing
Animal Crossing and we were like okay we
just need something on Netflix in the
background here there's a documentary on
Netflix
it's called tiger King it's about a guy
who owns who's called Joe exotic and he
owns I think the America's biggest
private big cat zoo and we were like
okay that's fine and I actually
recognized that guy because he was part
of a Lois through documentary about
keeping big cats a few years ago you
think it's just gonna be about you know
like the people who keep big cats in
America know it like there's an
attempted murder plot there is Joe
exotic and he's like running for
governor and he has his own singles and
he has two husbands and it's just the
wildest documentary I've ever seen and
then Episode two is when there are
there's just so many revelations in a
row that we're all sat there trying to
play an animal crossing looking at all
these people messing around with huge
tigers and lions and then just these
plot revelations don't even plot
revelations because it happens in real
life they just keep coming
and it was it's unbelievable like the
damage and the reason they have so much
access is because there was an there was
a camera crew there who were trying to
film reality series and they have all
this footage and then it turned into
this documentary did you guys yeah yeah
no one no one moved and I was like okay
is this me yeah it's like a UH is
someone using the Internet well when she
said messing around with Tigers I
thought it I thought that I didn't meant
I didn't interpret that properly
[Laughter]
I am going to yeah oh there we go
we lost you you were frozen we had a
conversation for about 30 seconds about
I know I oh yeah oh oh well maybe just
pick up from the reality TV series bit
okay so they have all this access
because a few years ago a reality TV
crew went to shoot a document it show
about Joe exotic and his his animals and
then as [ __ ] kept hitting the fan a
documentary filmmaker got involved and
then they have a ton of footage that
they managed to get to and the resulting
thing is just it's wild
it's so good and it's really well made I
think it's seven or so episodes we did
them across the weekend playing Animal
Crossing the whole time it's really good
it's like Netflix knew that we had
nothing else going on and just decided
to drop this it's really good it's true
crime elements in it which is yeah I
started watching it I was like oh I'm
building a desk I just bought a desk
because if people are looking at my like
background there's nothing in here
because I have no furniture basically I
like you got some cool posters though
yeah they're like the round here
somewhere and moved here and I didn't
buy any furniture cuz I was like I'll
take my time I don't have to eat a
massive upfront cost for furniture I'll
get the basics and then I'll slowly add
to it and then we had this thing happen
coronavirus was like oh I really need
all the furniture right now but like I
got a desk and I was like I'm gonna
build this desk and watch tiger King it
took me about seven hours to build a
desk because I kept stopping to watch
what was happening on the screen so I'm
like trying to screw something and I'm
like what what who is threatening who
because it starts off looking like like
Lucy's broken it down quite eloquently
about what it is but like you think it's
just gonna be like rivalries between
these big cat owners because they're
exotic pegs pets everyone wants to be
a kind of you know the big cat owner
extraordinaire then there's a lady who's
like Errol yeah Carol who's like we
should free we need to get these we need
to get these cats away from Jags Ike
he's mistreating them but she's running
her own Park and is like there's
something there's a we won't i won't
same way it's below that's the one that
took me the longest to does this biggest
slowdown because you like excuse me she
did walk and you're like she's like the
the the thing that a level at her is
like alright this is not about cats
anymore this is straight-up true crime
and then it keeps escalating to the
point where you like why is there an
undercover investigation why is the FBI
involved and you're like quad and like
it's everyone everyone is a character
and there's moments where if you stop if
you don't remind yourself that this is
reality TV it looks scripted it looks
all fake but their YouTube channels
still live by the way so if you finish
the documentary you can go back and look
at Joe exotic TV hmm and it is trip
basics like you see this them shoot that
stuff in the show and then you can watch
it on YouTube it's if you're like a you
know true crime slash you know murderer
you know you will very quickly identify
exactly like you very quickly identify
how these people are all cult leaders
fascinating like they all have the
hallmarks of a cult leader they do
things that are like it's eerily
reminiscent of like Heaven's Gate
various other well-known cult leaders
their like personality wise they are
cult leaders and the and like the really
cool thing about it is like it brings
back brings it back to like how the cats
are affected in an interesting way not
in a super in-depth way but it's in a
way that like you forget that cats are a
big part of this and then it'll remind
you and you're like oh [ __ ] I can't
believe it's the people were the real
monsters the entire time I really
thought you're gonna say I can't believe
you've done this
I mean like I fully I fully can't
believe they've done any of that
it's very very good on Netflix yeah and
so that's what I've been obsessed with
I'm up to the I'm on the memes now they
have a lot of Joe exact memes
yeah why does name joe exotic well cuz
his real name is Joe tribe BOGO yeah so
we did a John he did the John Cougar
then but he needs like a standout name
he's won in a brand yeah does he have a
brand it's funny if he'd gone with
cougar John Mellencamp
but exotic he's cool too I guess oh my
god I just remembered one thing that
happens that like when it happened on
screen loosely will know about it but
about know exactly unlike we were
playing crossing will just went it's
like George dropping cuz it's like it's
all like casual talking about people
being weird and then this they show this
something awful happens and then they
show it and you're like oh my god how do
they show that it's it's like if so far
it's messed up my stuff there's the
tiger kill someone okay also like
there's a lot of very very very
beautiful animals in it but also no tell
you I feel very confident saying none of
those people are beautiful oh well
anyway
two more what have you been up to apart
from you know doing you your blood-borne
grind so blood-borne grind is still
happening it's the anniversary of
blood-borne it was a couple days ago
great game everyone should play it
I started playing bleeding edge I
haven't played that much of it so I
won't speak to in depth of that equality
what I will say is it's an interesting
game they're trying to go for that like
overwatch style more II player
experience where it's like super bright
super vibrant really charismatic really
distinct interesting looking characters
but do it in a third-person combat game
its developer Ninja Theory the team
behind
Heavenly Sword hell blade hell bleats
and your sacrifice DMC Devil May Cry so
they have the the chops for combat stuff
I don't think it's particularly fluid it
feels satisfying ish I done basically
all of the training stuff on and I
messed around with a bunch of the
characters there's one character who is
Taika Waititi doink org and it's very
I'm very into that character he's like a
robot he's like I think he's a Maui or
like Samoan character but he's got like
he's also part robot and his ability is
he just does loads of slaps so he just
does this loads he does you press the
attack button you hold it and he just
does this the entire time and then you
took you can just walk so like I'm just
walking around arenas just slapping the
[ __ ] out of everyone and then his
ability is like an escape ability where
he runs away really fast but he says leg
it in in the cogs voice so I like run up
to people slap him and then go leg it
and run away
I'm just running around their game
annoying the [ __ ] out of people and it's
got like a bunch of mode standard fare
like capture the objective grab these
power cells put them in there and it's
really weird it's got this it's got this
mismatch between what is always like
this cartoony futuristic vibe but the
soundtrack is like weird EDM concert
happening in a desert like Tiesto has
done the soundtrack or something and
it's very very confusing so totally
quite confusing but ninja Terry's really
known for like creating visually
distinct and charismatic characters they
didn't slave so that kind of vibe is in
this there's like an old lady who's kind
of a witch there's Korg but a samurai
there's like a dude who is effectively
Lucio but laying down in a hover bike
the entire time it's really yeah it's
it's really interesting I I kind of
don't know why they made it it feels
like it was a project that they had to
they were working on as like a sub
project as a passion project
before they got acquired by Microsoft
when it was like we need something
remember when they made that mobile game
so there's a mobile game they made a
little while back and it came back when
mobile game was hot were hot and it was
like very much made to be a
microtransaction game effectively it was
we need money how do we get that money
make a mobile game this kind of has that
whether or not it is it kind of has that
vibe to it where it's like everyone's
making multiplayer games team based
abilities that kind of stuff we need one
of those that's the trend that will help
us kind of stay afloat for a bit longer
but no no obviously Microsoft came in
and purchased them and now they're fine
and like they're stable but they still
put the game out so I it's it's got like
ideas and it's interesting and it's
functional but I don't know how much the
life it's got in it it's like it's been
put out to die it very much has there's
like no more zero marketing it's a few
days after Animal Crossing and doom day
after half-life so it's a shame but I
mean hopefully I feel like Ninja Theory
were acquired for hell-blade right I
mean yeah like if this was you know just
to kind of like tech test ash is am i
okay I'm spending too long indoors but
you know what I mean it's like not to
diminish the work of the people who've
been on it it just feels like a shame to
put all this hard work on and then it
just gets as a studio like Ninja Theory
sorry Jake um go ahead i I think the
thing to to remember is that it is free
right if you've got xbox game pass and I
think that's kind of what they're
banking on with this you know like it'll
find its audience yeah it may take a
while but it'll find its audience and
I'm sure you know if you log into Xbox
and you have game pass I'm sure it's one
of the first things that shows up like
hey check out this brand-new game that's
available today and you can download it
and play it and it's kind of like
overwatch but also has these other weird
characters so maybe maybe they're just
banking on that yeah it's it's I turned
my xbox on specifically to get it and I
was like oh god I'm gonna
to fight my way through the Xbox you I
could find this game and it was like
front and center right there I was like
great so I'm like okay game like that
lives or dies in his community it should
have had a bigger purse yes ninja theory
the acquisition of Ninja Theory like you
mentioned it's for help late but like I
adore that studio I think they've done
some amazing work and partly why I like
them also is because they're the
underdog studios always they always put
out the under they love to put themself
in a position worse like let's make a
game and make it even more and up all of
an uphill struggle then ordinarily is
like between hell-blade being a triple-a
game made on a double-a budget and then
taking on Devil May Cry and basically
painting a target on the entire studios
back they always do amazing work so I
think the acquisition from Microsoft is
gonna pay off dividends beyond just help
late they're incredibly creative and
small and they think outside of the box
and the reason I mentioned that is
because despite the despite what this is
and whether it succeeds it still got the
ninja theory polish it's got the ninja
theory engineering creativity and it's
got like the the outside of the box
thinking that people who like that
studio expect from them so it might be
like a cynical of a kind of like
released to cash in on the multiplayer
thing but they've at least done the work
and put in the effort to make it cool so
I would recommend if you have game pass
try it it's fun it's got some quirky
characters maybe you'll like Korg who
slaps people and then legs it like I do
it's worth a try cool yeah I think when
things slow down I might try it because
I do like most of the right I mean every
ninja theory game I've played I've
enjoyed haven't played all of them but I
think it's something I'm definitely
going to check out eventually if you're
playing it we have Jordan has written up
tips on how to be good eye on the
website and it'll give you a leg up
anyone out there who's trying to get
into it have a read but right now my
attention is mostly focused on half life
I've been playing I played Black Mesa a
couple weeks ago I finished half-life 2
this
morning before work actually for the
first time and I recently just started
half-life 2 episode 1 and last week I
talked a little bit about my experience
with half-life 2 and I said I wasn't
super wild about it but I I i I think
the big thing is that because I never
played it back in the day the tech like
it just didn't have the same effect on
me so I it was hard for me to get drawn
in but now that I finished it I quite
enjoyed it I really enjoyed it I mean I
can see why people love that series what
people love that game I still think the
beginning is slow and I think I like
Black Mesa more than half-life 2 or I
guess half-life 1 I didn't play
half-life on but I played Black Mesa I
just really liked that confined feeling
of half-life 1 and how it's all just in
one area 51 like area yeah there we go
area 51 like area way to go Jake but
having finished half-life 2 it like I
wish I wish I played it back it when it
first came out I think I would have been
blown away by it if I played it back
then however I just started episode 2 or
episode 1 sorry and I'm into it like I'm
I'm enjoying it I have been playing
half-life Alex which we'll talk about a
little bit later but I had to stop
because everyone I talked to was like
yeah you I mean the first half of Alex
doesn't have a whole lot of story stuff
to it it's pretty straight forward but I
hear the second half if you haven't
played half-life episode half-life 2
episode 1 and half-life episode Jesus
half-life 2 episode 2 it can be really
tough to follow along and a lot of the
big revelations won't pay off as much if
you haven't played those so I'm really
looking forward to continue to
continuing this half-life journey
definitely when I started half-life 2 I
was like great I've got you know I've
got one game I have to get I forgot one
more game I have to get through and then
two halves of a game I have to get
through after that but now I'm pretty
into and I'm enjoying it and I think a
lot of the level design is super
creative the puzzles you do are very
creative the combats maybe because I'm
flipping between doom but which is like
you know balls to the wall crazy combat
it's
kind of slow and like you know you just
got your standard like pistol shotgun
and the gravity gun which everyone loved
at the time is like meat but it's not
really what I want to use ever until the
end anyway that was my half-life to rant
how are you finding I like so what are
you playing yelling I am playing on the
quest which has been an experience to
say the least I ran into a lot of issues
early on I was about to give up playing
Alex altogether turns out that if when I
plugged my oculus quest into my
motherboard directly it works a lot
better I was talking to Matt Padgett
apparently he hasn't had that issue even
though he's doing it on a quest so I
think it is just my pc being an old
piece of [ __ ] the old piece of [ __ ] that
it is just was having issues running it
when I plugged it into the case as
opposed to the motherboard once I did
that I was able to actually play the
game without the headset locking up
every couple minutes which you know that
that's that helps a ton it still doesn't
run as good as I like and I think part
of that might be because I got a
knockoff cable and I didn't even get the
one that oculus recommended because they
they have an oculus link cable an
official one but you can't get it right
now I think if you get it it's like 150
dollars absurd it's just a USB C to a
USB 3.0 but they recommend you buy an
anchor cable off Amazon which is I don't
know some company that makes which did
you switch no cuz it's not 3.0 it's 2.0
so I had to order it mine is I think so
maybe not I might try it but but even
then right yeah what's that yeah - I've
been then like I need one long though
you know cause I'm moving around so I
ordered like an anchor cable a long ones
hopefully that works better than the one
I have
other than that though it's running fine
enough especially if I'm not moving
around too much I feel like when I am
push all my furniture aside and I try to
play with like a larger area then it has
some trouble but if I'm kind of
stationary for the most part it seems to
run okay unless I start moving my
super quickly then it can take a while
for I don't know whatever I'm looking at
to load in I was literally about to say
yeah I I haven't played I think the
longest I played was ninety minutes and
that was a little too much in one
sitting I I've been trying to slow down
and like I said I stopped playing
because I am about halfway through now
and I don't want to see the rest of the
game until I know what happened and the
other episodes and they'd spoil the
ending of one of the episodes right at
the beginning of half-life Alex it's
like out great well yeah but yeah yeah I
don't know if it's spoiling at this
point but I it's super impressive even
on my quest it is I am blown away at
almost every aspect of the game so far
and apparently I haven't even hit the
level that everyone's talking about
those apparently one of the best shooter
levels in games at least that's what
people are saying now maybe it's just
because it's new and people haven't seen
a half-life game in God knows how long
13 years or whatever
Michael hyeme said it and I was like
Michael gets hype and I and I do trust
him but he's also like yo this is insane
about everything and then like I was
then I was like watching the kind of
funny review of it and noted half-life
fun Danny O'Dwyer was like it's like a
game-changer this this bit and I was
like okay Danny's a a you know a noted
half-life fan so he's inclined to like
it as well and then Greg was like yeah
it's crazy it's it's really good and I
was like alright okay yeah see see
that's throwing it here because I've
only heard Michael and Danny talk about
this level and I was like alright you
guys have been wanting half-life for a
long time so I want to get to swept away
in this yet but I haven't made it to
that point yet but I'm very excited to
see what it is because as of now like
it's already a great game in my opinion
if not a fantastic game so I'm excited
to see how and what exactly happens but
just the way you interact with the
environment is so cool I feel like you
feel way more present than any other
vr game I've played I wish to be fair
I'm not big in the VR I have a quest
I've played some games like I played the
Star Wars well I mean the quest is kind
of like you buy the quest if you don't
have a PC that can handle one of the
higher-end headsets and McCann play a
lot of the hardcore but you know they're
like they're people like Matt who's like
listing off all these Matt Pat who's
listing off all these like crazy VR
games that he's played and like yeah I
can do any of those but having played
having played some VR games I so far I'm
very impressed like the way that just
the environment reacts to you as you're
as you're moving through like shelves
trying to find something away you knock
things over with your hands as you're
picking things up or like drawing dicks
on whiteboards drawing dicks on
whiteboards I told John Luke to do it on
the stream but he didn't want to do it
equation one yeah the math equation
one's amazing yeah mention really
quickly before we're too far from the
Michael and Danny discussion is that as
the reviews editor I'm obligated to say
but also I believe this that Michael
does go into a review understanding that
his excitement is not the same as a oh
yeah yeah yeah I was I was specifically
talking about that moment not the review
as a whole my review Michael will like
come up to you I mean obviously we're
not in the office right now but he'll
come into the office be like you all
this shit's fire and it's just a cup of
water and he's like yeah I mean I'm Greg
Greg's angle was like he'd not played
any half-life before so that's why I was
like okay it's yes three people on
different scales of liking it are saying
it's gotta be legit and like I I don't
have the five in valve index I want one
but it's a thousand dollars yeah yeah
we've we've got one
I mean Greg's got one and I might try
and hook it up like I have space in my
room
which is only preserved try do yoga in
it but like I've space in my room that I
could set it up but my I mean my biggest
fear my biggest barrier to entry for VR
is motion sickness to get it real bad I
think that will definitely be an issue
with this game hey I have heard the vibe
is a bit
I was watching interview and they say
the best one that I've ever played but I
still felt motion sick after playing
five sorry I guess the review the review
so they said the index they actually
didn't prefer playing on the index they
preferred playing on an oculus I don't
remember which one or maybe it was a
vive pro or something like that yeah I
don't know why that is but I don't know
yeah I get sick and I usually don't get
sick from VR games but it's only because
I spent like two and a half hours
playing one time yeah I mean I felt so
bad for Michael but he doesn't really
get sick in VR but having reviewed then
it's like every half hour it had to take
the headset off and be like okay it's
how to breathe eat some ginger I have a
friend of mine got an oculus development
kit one when they first came out and he
modded it to play half-life 2 that is
probably the most sick I've ever been in
VR what's on line two in VR it's really
annoying because like a lot of people I
love half-life and I've been waiting for
a new half-life for ages and i'm like
nafta paying $900 and potentially be
sick because i get it i get carsick and
motion sick very badly so I was like oh
god but I think I'm gonna try and Nick
the work index and give it a shot Ellie
ii say I tried yeah yeah right I want to
try it with like have you seen those
seasickness bands that you can put on
your wrist and like apparently they work
really well I've known people who tried
them who have like my a friend of mine
has really bad motion sickness playing
normal games I think I've told the story
on the podcast maybe before but my old
roommate Jen literally dry heaved her
way through the last of us she loved to
that game so much it was horrible for
everyone else but she did it she took a
lot of Dramamine and she's tried those
seasickness
ban and they have worked pretty well
so I wonder if that would help in VR too
because I've had a better time with
motion sickness in VR when I'm standing
up so I like using the vibe or even
using the the quest like playing super
hot I've done that and super hot isn't a
lot of movement when you're actually in
it but I wonder if that would help
that'd be nice yeah yeah I mean I will
say that this is valve developed of
course and there are a lot of different
settings you can tweak to change around
like what kind of movement style you
prefer look style whatever it might be
which I think hopefully helps people a
lot but yeah overall I am super
impressed with it so far I like it makes
it makes me really excited for for to
see what VR is gonna look like in a
couple years maybe even longer because
like what they've done with this game it
finally feels like okay i vr is is a
legitimate platform that can have some
really cool experiences that you can't
do anywhere else and i've seen glimpses
of that before for sure like beat saber
when I first played beat saber that was
incredible but if you like almost every
moment in half-life Alex there's
something just like the way you can use
your environment like the headcrabs for
not the head well the head crabs are a
whole nother story but what are the what
are the barnacles that hang from the
ceiling that have their little tongues
that if you get caught in you get
carried up oh I think they all barnacles
yeah I think they're barnacles but like
oh well you can get through them now is
like I'll pick up a can and throw it at
its tongue and then it'll get dragged up
and then I'll sneak by it or like or
I'll get into firefights frantically and
like you could oh just press a button to
reload right because it's VR you have to
like grab a magazine out of your
backpack you have to eject the other
magazine you have to slide it in and
then you have to like close the close
quote I forget what it's called
basically like get ready to fire bullets
pull the hammer back and like I'll be
freaking out because something will be
near me I'll be out of ammo or whatever
and all like reload and put in a new
magazine and I'll still be panicking
I'll hit the wrong button and eject my
magazine
I'll be frantically trying to get my
magazine up again and reload before they
before the headcrab gets to me and then
like you can snatch headcrabs out of the
air if they're coming out you can grab
them and like throw them off to the side
and it is just the level of interact
interactivity is absurd yeah I'm
enjoying the pictures on videos of
people like grabbing headcrabs out of
the air and just like dancing with them
and posing them and doing stuff like
that that's why I or label on Twitter I
saw similar like oh yeah so you only
have two inventory slots apart from
where you store your ammo you've got
them on your wrists you can hold one
thing in each of your wrists or I saw
someone just like throw a bunch of
useful stuff into a basket and then just
carry the basket around the level with
them which I thought was that was really
clever I will say the one thing that is
a little worrisome is that with all the
money that half life or that Valve has
like the movement in VR is still so
limiting like I don't know is it
teleporting you can you can search
between teleporting or moving but or
like using a control stick to move or
you can move around a small environment
depending on how big your play area is
and it's I guess it's not something they
can really solve but like that's like
the biggest thing holding back VR is
that you're always stuck in a certain
area and that was the exciting thing
about quest right was that you can draw
out giant areas anywhere to do that
you're not tethered to a computer
anything like that
but with this it it still does feel
pretty limiting like especially in the
space I'm an I'm in more often than not
I'll collide with walls or even earlier
today I knocked over my water all over
my desk because I was swinging my arms
around like an idiot but yeah that's
what I have to say about half-life Alex
I am incredibly impressed and I'm very
excited to continue once I'm done with
half-life episode 1 and 2 half-life 2
episode 1 in episode 2 no the sirens are
on again they're after me oh yeah every
time on a Wednesday I want you there
after it's Wednesday's our fire trucks
Darwin's what did you witness
Jake quoting a vine clipping yeah anyway
I think that's about it for half-life
Alex unless you guys have any questions
or any I don't know I did like when we
doing the podcast run she early and I
was like what's the big news stories for
this week it's like well the what the
world's kind of figuring out the new
normal the Olympics got cancelled I
thought they just got postponed or
postponed but I bet you yeah somewhere
Mario and Sonic are very confused right
now was gonna shout out Chloe rad did a
bunch of half-life content with the help
other people of course and that includes
like a really hefty Easter eggs guide
and a full accessibility guide to nice
there are some crazy Stu eggs did you
know someone found someone found a
bridges box like yeah that's pretty cool
yeah dis [ __ ] because there was a
death stranding tie-in in the PC version
of death stranding right for those ahead
crap um oh yeah the PC version of the
surrounding that sweet it's a just
ranting ISM present it had G but right
now this is the time to or play it and
also not play it yeah yeah I was like I
was looking out my window wistfully the
other day and thinking remember when
Amazon were like we're gonna do drone
deliveries and everyone went what no
you're not that stupid never do that
we're them drones up if we hadn't shiet
down I mean Amazon sucks and Jeff Bezos
can eat my ass but like you know if we
had the drone deliveries everything
would be legit toilet paper coming
through your window imagining it imagine
if deaths training got the lay a couple
months came out
now I literally into that review saying
that this was the game we need right now
and now look you see you should do an
update I just put at the end update no
right now actually
anyway as Lucy said there wasn't a whole
lot of news this week I feel like it was
a lot of big game releases and a lot of
playing the games yeah everyone's too
busy playing games and trying to figure
out what the hell to do right now but
anyway should we move on to listen to
questions Lucy do you want to take the
first actually cally why'd you take the
first one before we do that if you have
any questions please email us at after
dark podcast at gamespot.com yeah go
ahead
hey crew I am excited Animal Crossing
come I am excited to the ampulla cross
he's coming out tomorrow but I have
never played Animal Crossing or any
similar games what are some tips you
would give a new player of Animal
Crossing in this style in general that
is from DM sky well if you're looking
for tips we have tons on gamespot.com
that's why I put this in I was like yeah
let's plug all those videos Manny
honestly like cueing those videos and
looking at the scripts before they went
live ahead of the game launching I was
like I'm ready yeah I I I rewatched all
of them as well as watching Tiger king I
rewatched all those videos with the
Animal Crossing guys while I was
building furniture so for like maybe
four hours one day there was just Jake's
voice coming out of my bedroom your
wages yeah I have been really excited to
write all these Animal Crossing Goods
because one summer I read when wild
world came out I had a wild world like a
physical guide and I ran it cover to
cover multiple times because I was I
don't know I always wanted to be a guide
writer so it was just it's been fun to
write the Animal Crossing guides but I
would say like I guess my biggest tip
would be like there's no wrong way to
play animal
crossing there are ways to like
fast-track certain things from happening
but I think especially considering what
we talked about earlier in the episode
you'll probably have a better time if
you just kind of like do what seems
interesting talk to your villagers you
know Tom Nook and and Timmy have advice
at the beginning of the game which will
help a lot and give you a little bit of
direction as will the Nook miles program
because you'll get rewards for doing
different things that'll kind of like
push you in a direction but as long as
you're enjoying it and it's relaxing for
you and giving you what you want out of
that game then you're playing it right
so just do that and look at all of our
guides and watch all of our guide videos
who's gonna say something similar and
then just take it one day at a time like
there's all these different tips you can
look at but I think the best thing you
can do in Animal Crossing is just like
you know check in every day figure out
what you want to do that Dave do that or
don't do that baby just ice around it's
just like a relaxing game to be in most
of the time like I played it last night
before I went to bed and it was just
like such a nice way to unwind
I guess just hearing that music and
doing some fishing and chatting with
villagers I think one of the key things
to try and do your best to not get
caught up in is the zeitgeist around
Animal Crossing it's both a blessing and
a curse like everyone is talking about
Animal Crossing right now and sharing
stuff and it's very wholesome and
enjoyable but I've also seen people be
like I'm so behind I need to catch up
with people and I need to try and get
this I need to get that and I need the
ladder would someone give me the ladder
I don't have this fruit and it honestly
don't try and catch up with people just
play at your own pace and don't try to
think about min maxing sometimes it can
be good just to pop into your game and
the only thing you've done that day is
just shake all the trees don't have to
do the shake all the trees pick the
weeds get the wood that kind of stuff
just do a bit at a time at your own pace
and let everyone live their own Animal
Crossing life and you live yours and
occasionally or intersect very naturally
and it will be way more
fulfilling because of that cool is the
advice Lucy do you want to take the next
one I gave you a long one sorry but they
mentioned GameSpot UK so I was like it's
gotta be one of you two that's what I
after dark crew I've been a longtime
listener of GameSpot UK podcasts long
time ago and I've only recently found
out about this one so I've been
listening to some of the back tracks I
doubt that many of you will remember but
I have also sent several questions the
UK crew and vividly remember Lucy into
Moore's lovely voices and it was a great
time walking back to memory lane when
they were in GameSpot UK mm-hmm a lot
has changed for me during that time
including graduating University and
after a whirlwind of career changes have
managed to find a place in a video game
company so it's kind of a dream come
true for me congratulations
nice yeah I am very happy with my job
with lots of perks such as free video
games but while I thought it was a
blessing at first it soon became a
burden when I realized I don't have as
much free time as I used to when I was a
student I now have the money and the
games to play and spend but with very
little time to do so the little time I
do have tends to be playing on
multiplayer games and such as Cod and
apex legends with my friends and I could
only spend about an hour or two on
single-player games I want to complete
as video game journalist I have no doubt
you're in seventh position of having
access to so many games you want to play
through but I want to ask you the
veterans of work life video gamers and
how you managed to create time to play
and complete video games also I have so
many backlogs of old and new games I
need to play and I'm having a hard time
deciding which ones to complete first
I'll lay out the top 5 games I want to
complete during the outbreak so I'd love
to hear your opinions number one the
outbreak outbreak number one neo to
number two Dragon Quest 11 on ps4 3
Catherine full body for Shadow of the
Colossus 5 control as always please keep
up the good work and stay safe best
wishes Erik song
well congratulations Eric thank Sarah
and thank you for writing in and time
that you've remember me and two more
from like yeah 2011 2012 when we won the
games what UK podcast I don't know I'm
in a I'm in a similar boat in that
obviously there's so many to play and
around game of the time you feel like
you have to have played pretty much
everything that's up for contention I am
really bad for I've noticed that I spend
a lot of time on my phone which I'm
trying to do a lot less and instead I'm
trying to use that time instead of just
refreshing to Arawa whatever to actually
play games setting aside some time
during the week even it's just an hour
to get through a game can also help kind
of I think that's I talked about this
briefly last week but talking about
making a new schedule for yourself and
if you're on lockdown then hey you don't
have you commute anymore maybe turn that
hour into a gaming hour or something you
know what I mean it's just all about
like coughing up your time so that you
can play a few more games not having to
commute has helped a lot yeah like I
finished half-life this morning cuz
normally I'd be commuting but is like
yeah that work doesn't start for another
hour and a half so I'm gonna finish up
half-life 2 thanks yeah I think not
which order I was gonna say which order
for these five games yeah that's us
thinking about cuz my thing my thing
with this was just gonna be like I I
really just prioritize the games I most
want to play rather than the ones okay I
need to play that it that is very hard
for me come game of the year time and I
do have to take more time when I'm not
like playing a game I'm really invested
in to try those games up this I would
probably just say I mean just personally
I would prioritize controlled but this
is me I would say maybe if you want to
feel like you are actually completing
stuff go for the shorter game so Shadow
the Colossus and control a much shorter
and you can actually feel like hey
you're getting that sense of completion
ISM because you're doing it the Colossus
is like broken up as well so you could
do a colossi a day and you get and
because of the that kind of build-up to
finding the colossi fighting the colossi
and then coming back it's like a really
good like whole loop of a game that's
really really like it you will feel
satisfied and feel like you've achieved
something with
each colossi also its a banger
but then controls coming out and this
control dlc control dlc is coming out so
you could also hit that yeah I can
wrestle ugh this is amazing no yeah not
for Xbox dragon quests are not amazing
but is it time think it's one of those
ones I like to sometimes suggest people
have like a short term or a short person
game where they plan to finish it within
a couple weeks or a month and then one
that they play like for a prolonged
period of time and Dragon Quest is a
good one to play over a long period of
time because a big old grand adventure
so like taking your time with that is a
good way to approach that game Dragon
Quest is also structured in an
interesting way where each new area you
get to has like its own little plot and
story that feeds into the main narrative
so it's kind of there's a lot of natural
breaks throughout it I would say I still
haven't finished that game I've been
playing it very slowly now but yeah I
think I agree I would say start with
control and shadow of Colossus because
you can probably finish those much
quicker than the other three you've got
here and also neo 2 is supposed to be
like 120 hours isn't it yeah yeah and
it's super hard yeah unless you're
really good then I mean I I mean let's
go some cheap [ __ ] in that game it's no
blood-borne is that what you're trying
to say
not a few things almond should move on
to the last one or do we have anything
to add to that I mean also just fun yeah
yeah you're pressurized into playing
games just could everyone else's like
what you guys are saying about Animal
Crossing I don't feel like you're
needing to do what everyone else is
doing just play what you want playing
playing the multiplayer games like the
way it's worded I know there's no way
means per like it's almost like I'm
doing this instead of doing something
having a more meaningful gaming
experience but playing multiplayer with
friends and even if it's the same game
all the time try and reframe that in
your mind as being as valuable I was
playing one of these brand-new games I
think there's something I
go with like I play a lot of overwatch
and often to the detriment of other
games but it's always fun and I have a
good time I play with my friends and
chat with them and it's as valuable to
me as like starting a brand new game and
thinking well mm to that so try and take
the pleasure out of those regular games
as well especially now it's probably
good to play some games with friends
right now good some get some social
interactions in Tim or do you want to
read the less so and this is an
interesting one you're gonna need to
send this listeners gonna need to send
us a screenshot of what are we talking
about
that's go ahead hi they lockdown crew
Gerard from the Netherlands here so my
mom got Animal Crossing for the switch
and she's been loving it she's been an
avid fan since world world under the
original DES and for as long as I can
remember me and my younger sister have
always been giving her useful tips and
tricks to get certain items or fish or
events and such however this time around
she told me she's gone unbreakable
shovel on the second day of playing
she's a liar
lying I'm not your mom's a liar a
villager gave it to her and now I'm
incredibly jealous that shovel should
have been mine I've always been the one
with the good stuff and tips this is
totally on this is so totally unfair so
my question to you is have you ever been
jealous of someone else's achievement in
a video game we need we need to see
evidence of this has ever given a tool
as a gift this is no because I have
gotten a tool as a gift mm-hmm if it
turns out this person's if it turns out
Gerard's mother is a liar and has been
lying about this what does that say
about everything else his mother has
told him in life if like this could be
like what they also have you lied to me
about mother what else maybe it's not an
unbreakable but maybe it's like a go a
gold one or something that's just really
good we need the receipts
we need the receipts idea I'm gonna need
proof I personally have never gotten a
tool as a gift so I got a shovel early
on one of the characters gave me a
shovel because they were like hey I hear
you're trying to build a shop here's the
shovel this might help you out I was
like okay I think I got a Warren can the
same way yeah the wooden one okay now
now that that's what I'm jealous F to
answer Gerard's question I would say I
have been jealous of people's ability to
do things in games I guess or gel like
especially jealous of like a really good
Pokemon or like a shiny pokemon oh yeah
I think I don't know if I'm envious of
anything really sometimes I'll watch a
play of the game and over watch I'm like
damn I wish I could play like that I
mean I kind of do that so myself i watch
a lot of shroud and you know he's he's
younger than me he used to be a pro
Counter Strike player I'll never have
the reflexes that he has but I would say
yeah it's nothing it's out of my control
there I can still play the game and
enjoy them hmm yeah I I would say my
jealousy stems from like a lack of like
other people who are really good at
video games and I'm just like dang I'm
like kind of just okay at video games
like hey like I'm a lot of people think
that because we're in this industry or
all really good at video games but it's
not always the case I feel like we're
all above average at video game stuff
you take like yeah yeah I'm sure we are
like I'm decent at siege I'm decent at
some of these other games but then I see
like friends who I play with who like
are really good at call of duty and I'm
like how how like I I should be better I
think I play more and I'm not I'm
jealous of other people's time so like
my brother is really really good at
video games and I got I like through I
actually likes threw a fit because he
beat me in
it was just like a friendly thing we
were doing and I like got upset just
because it's like well you know I have
just you know I spent all my time trying
to get in a good college I didn't get to
play Halo all the time so I'm not good
at like I just got so I definitely had
moments like that he didn't get heated
gaming moments if you will I think like
I ever like I I know that I can be good
at a game if I tried and I'm happy with
that and not at knowing that just like
back in the day I used to play Street
for a comparable super high and I know
that any game that I put my if I want to
be good at it and have the time to put
you know into it I can be good at it so
like I'm okay with knowing that I have
the capacity to be good more than
actually being good whenever whenever I
see someone like that does something
amazing I was like I could probably do
that by just out of time to try right
now like I'm happy with my Zarya play
I'm good I'm happy thank you very much
I'm happy with my abilities and flying
games like I know that if I got back
into Counter Strike I want to be Shroud
obviously but like I can still
point-and-click really well I'm good so
like the only thing I and also like the
one achievement I have one trophy one
Planum trophy and it's blood-borne and
after I did that I was like I don't care
about anything else
myself yeah I don't have to prove myself
to anyone or anything like and I like
I'm great
Sakura so I'm like I'm fine I can still
I still got it I'm just old and I don't
have the time
stuff likes yeah I can flex what I need
to that's a good outlook yeah anyway
that's been episode 34 of GameSpot after
dark thank you so much for tuning in and
bearing with us as we get used to this
new setup if you have any questions
please email at us at after dark podcast
at gamespot.com you can also email us if
you want access to the discord because
like I said it should be all up and
running by Friday or you can just DM
Gianluca myself and we'll make sure to
get you in there Kalli where can people
find you on twitter you can find me on
twitter
pinkey does iike i nko I do ji kko
anything to plug lots of animal crossing
stuff I imagine lots of a almost
crashing stuff please take a look at ya
we also have the cost of almost every
single fish in bug right we have logged
almost every fishing bug yeah and
that'll be a useful resource to
definitely look at that is that you're
not just cost but also location time of
year time of day damn Lucia where can
people find you I am on Twitter at Lucy
James games and in terms of plugs
Tom and I are breaking down reviewing
Westworld every week youtube.com slash
games but universe season 3 is good
thank God because season 2 almost lost
me at some points but on every watch
it's very good in season three starts
off strong next week stuff to look out
for we have audio logs with chigan
origin so Dima character artist on
persona 5 which is very exciting that
were you wearing that sweater yeah I am
and dave is doing a really cool video
about the BFG from doom and I watched a
rough cut of it today it was awesome
mm-hmm and more I mean this is plug
basically everything I have also
involved in yeah efficient I have a
feature on wait no the anime features
not for this week there's an anime
feature coming and there might be a
Animal Crossing feature coming later
this week as well I have to help on the
anime feature and it's killing me yeah
the the Animal Crossing feature is a
maybe it's actually written by one of
our on staff writers Kevin which and
it's just a great little story so I took
a video and then you can find me at
Jacob deck and there are a ton of Animal
Crossing guides that I wrote and
recorded and got lots of help from
much of our staff like Evan Max and
David so be sure to check those out let
us know what you think if you've got
another tips you leave them there as
well but I think that's it for this week
see y'all next day
[Music]